the last time you bought yourself  something really nice or fancy and what  was it I didn't find myself anything I'm  tight I'm tight probably this watch uh  IWC what was the last time you felt  frustrated half race again in Japan when  you're trying your hardest and as a team  we decided to pit and I thought it was  the wrong thing at the time and I felt  very frustrated obviously when you're in  the car all the emotions go in you get a  little bit hot-headed sometimes it's the  last country you went to for the first  time oh wow go to so many places I don't  even remember it's been years ago  [Music]  was the last time you felt like you  wanted to quit playing like a board game  was simple with my family and I'm losing  from racing I've never I've never felt  like